I think that's the dopest thing about
what you're talking about is like the
the not knowing how to do it and the
figuring it out and the completion of
figuring it out and then seeing it move
on and grow to be something else.
So even you're talking about just the
first couple of web series and then the
Awkward Black Girl came.
All right, s***, this comes and now
progresses and now has a following.
Wow. You're.
You're being sought after.
There's another conversation to be had
Now. It looks as if this thing is going
to propel you to the next stage of
entertainment. Yeah. What was that
moment?
When I found out that I was going to
that I was going to go to this next
level. Oh, my God, it came in.
You know, you have you know, you have
so many moments where it's like, oh,
this is about to be it and then it's
not. So I had a couple of those moments
just by interactions sometimes, you
know, when I when I had the opportunity
with Pharrell and he picked up our
second season, I was like, Oh, this is
this is opening me up to so many other
people to, to watch the show, to watch
our little web series and then through
that. Because he funded the second
season. We got reviewed in Rolling
Stone, and then Rolling Stone was seen
by Shonda Rhimes. And then, you know,
they saw that her company, Shondaland
saw that review. And then I got the
opportunity to create like one of their
first comedy pilots.
And that was like, Wow, this is my
television hero. There's no black
women.
Say, like, what is the the Shonda Rhimes
of it all for you at that moment like
you are?
She really?
In the same way that I didn't know
that. Oh, like when I shoot Awkward
Black Girl, there's hella people. There
are so many jobs.
I didn't really know what a showrunner
was. I knew that people wrote for
television. I knew that there were
writers rooms to an extent.
But to see a successful black woman
running a show, having a successful
series like Grey's Anatomy, then
But like really.
Like really successful running and like,
I didn't know even what that entailed
until, you know, I did it.
And then I was like, Oh my God, she was
really killing it. But that was just
like you. Sometimes you don't know what
you want to achieve until you see it.
And I felt like she was very much that
for me. And so by the time they called
me in, she had Scandal and Grey's
Anatomy on the Air and they were both
hit shows. And so for me, seeing her
immediately after our first meeting, I
did that thing where I was like, Can I
get a picture with you? Like, and it
was all the things you shouldn't do.
But you know, that's how I felt about
it.
What's your relationship with Shonda
now?
She's like just a mentor in a way.
And she's just she shows love and I'm
still a fan. Um, but you never.
Like, have you been able to sit down,
pick her brain? Like, I mean, after
that stage later on, I mean, you get to
where you are now. Have you ever tried
to double back and have the
conversations? Of course, and say, wow,
that moment was for me.
In Group settings.
But you know what I've realized and this
is I forget who I've access to even
talking to you sometimes I'm like.
I've gotten mad at you.
I know.
And I because I don't like to ask
people for help. And everybody's busy.
You're doing 70, 70 million things,
Ava's doing 70 million things.
Shonda is doing 70 million things
recently, like just on some whatever,
stuff like hit up Diddy like, because I
was going through something and it just
popped in my head.
I was going to hit him for something
else, something like social related,
and I was going through something
business wise and I was like, This man
literally does so many of the things
that I do and aspire to do.
I'm having this dilemma.
Let me just ask him.
And then like and then the advice that
he gave me and the wheelhouse was like
exactly what I needed at the time.
And I was like, Why don't I do this
more? So short answer, no, but I will
want to.
Long story short, Kevin.
No.
I don't know. I have not.
That's like the most important thing
that I feel people don't tap into.
But who do you tap into?
Everybody.
No, no, I don't believe it.
I'm 1,000% telling you the truth.
Everybody. That you literally ask
someone, Hey, what do I do for advice?
You have.
Everybody.
But not everybody do for people who are
you know, are very, very busy.
Every body.
All right, fine. All right.
There is not one person that will not
take your call when you're looking for
it. No, it's not.
You think that and that's what that's
what the problem is. Like people people
are in their own way because they're
you have the assumption that you're
going to think and I don't want you to
think because it's all based off of a
thought like you're creating a reaction
that hasn't even been had.
So nine times out of ten, if you really
do reach out, you'll be surprised how
many people go, Hey!
Oh, my God, Yo, it's crazy that you
call me. I'm a big fan. I just want to
say I love the work that you're doing.
What's up? What's going on?
Like, there's there's a synergy that's
lost because so many people stop
networking. So many people.
Will stop because you don't know if
people are genuine either. I mean,
you've you've extended that like,
credit to you. Like even in talking to
you, you've just been like, hit me, hit
me. And I'm like, this busy.
He lying. You told me one time.
No, you said you told me one time.
You said I hit you and you ain't hit me
back. I was like, All right. That's one
time I was like, D***.
I was like, So it's over.
What do you mean? I said, It's one time
I was shooting. I was out there country
like, All right, now you be saying that
s***. But I hit you one time.
I was like, It was one time.